every year more than four to five
million people died due to exposure to
outdoor air pollution around the world
this petri dish that you are looking at
contains approximately 20 minutes worth
of pollution captured of a pyrolysis
plant
this is pm 2.5 uh these particles you
can see it right now but i mean when
they're out there in the air you won't
see them these are so tiny that our
lungs our bodies cannot filter them and
they end up in our
inner bodies give us esthema and lung
cancer if not treated in the right time
on a trip back to india when i was a
student in 2012 i took this picture this
picture stuck in my head
on one side you see this exhaust of a
diesel generator the same generator
which is a sign of human progress which
is a sign of
in rapid industrialization and what we
have become as a society in the last 100
years generating energy but on the other
side you see this very interesting
triangular black colored swatch that is
produced by the same residual
particulate waste created by the
emissions of the generator
now this picture gave me an idea and got
me thinking about rethinking both
pollution and inks because it was making
that black colored mark now the reality
is that most of the black ink that we
use conventionally is traditionally
produced by
uh conventionally burning fossil fuels
in factories there are factories around
the world that are burning fossil fuels
to produce carbon black to make black
inks that we use on everyday basis
but given that millions of liters of
fossil fuels are already being burned
out there by our cars our engines and
our exhaust out there what if you could
capture that pollution and use it to
recycle and make those inks
i decided to give this experiment a shot
i went back to my lab back in boston and
conducted a small experiment in boston i
couldn't find much pollution to play
with so i resorted to using a candle
this was an experiment so i burnt a
candle built this contraption that would
suck in that candle soot
mix it with some vegetable oil and vodka
because after a diy hacker these were
really easily available and after
mixing them you could churn out a very
rudimentary form of ink that would go
into a cartridge and now you could print
with it this
was my hello world of experimenting with
printing with pollution
so this is the same pollution that i
showed you in the petri dish which is a
result of any fossil fuel that is being
burnt out there
in 2015 i decided to take this
experimentation forward and set up a lab
in india to work on capture and
recycling of air pollution
in the good times the lab used to look
something like this
but experimentations were not always
controlled and disasters happened and
while experimentation would happen the
lab would end up looking like something
like this
well we knew where we wanted to go but
we were not sure how exactly to reach
there the pastors by who used to go by
that lab through that building used to
at times things that these guys are
making bombs in there because there was
too much fire wires and smoke in the
same vicinity
we decided let's move to a garage and
take experiments forward we took a
garage and during the early stages we
were driving around bangalore with
contraptions like these this is the
early stage prototype and imagine the
looks people gave us what are these cars
driving around doing so this is an early
stage prototype of our system that would
capture pollution
that is being released from a
conventional diesel-based car
this is an early state of the technology
we advanced the technology and created
this into this version that would
capture pollution from static sources of
pollution like diesel generator if you
see all the fumes disappear as soon as
you turn this machine on
so
without affecting any
without affecting the performance of the
engine we are able to capture 95
worth of pollution released from the
diesel generator this
is the particulate matter that we are
talking about that we captured in this
case within three to four hours worth of
operation of a generator
in while our experiments and our
research was advancing
a very big company a very big brand
approached us and said we want to take
this idea further with you guys and take
this further in in a very big celebrated
form they said let's do a global art
campaign with the inks that you are
making of this pollution
i'll show you what the ink looks like
so
this pen
is made by recycling 40 to 50 minutes
off that car pollution that we're
talking about the same pollution that is
in the petri dish and it's a very sharp
black that you can write with
so i'm going to write
pm 2.5 that's and correct so this is a
very sharp black that is generated by
the same pollution
after much work on the lab level
research we got an offer from a vic
corporation to do a very big large trial
of this idea
and it happened to be a brand and we
didn't think twice we said let's let's
go ahead
inventing in the lab is one thing and
taking ideas and deploying it in the
real world is completely another
during early stages we had to resort to
using our own houses and our kitchens as
our ink making factories and our own
bedrooms and living rooms as the first
assembly line for making these inks
this is my co-founder nick hill's own
bedroom that is being used to supply
inks to artists all around the world who
would paint with airing and that's him
delivering earrings to the ports so that
the artists around the world can use it
soon we started seeing the thousands of
artists around the world started using
air ink and artwork started emerging
like this
soon thousands of black and white
pollution made artwork started emerging
on a global scale and believe me for a
group of scientists and engineers and
inventors there was nothing more
satisfying that the produce of their
work is now being used by some of the
finest artists around the world
this is the cover of contagious magazine
last year that was done by using the
same ink that we made back in our labs
this is a famous painting by the british
artist christian fur who painted it for
the song painted black by rolling stones
now there is more to this pen and this
ink than just the popular and pop
culture artworks and now our goal is to
create a company that can actually make
some black money i mean just money
and high quality printing processes and
inks
that can that can replace the
conventional black inks that have been
produced for last thousands of years
around the world
soon after our growing popularity and
artworks around the world we started
getting facing a very different kind of
a problem we started getting spammed by
polluters who would send us bags full of
pollution to our office address asking
us what can we do with this pollution
our lab back in bombay right now has
pollution samples that have come from
london
from india from china you name it and
this is just the beginning
this polluter sent us this specific
image asking us that this is these are
all the bags full of pm 2.5 and can we
recycle it for him if we paid him some
money
well what would he have done if we did
not take that pollution he would
probably find the nearby river or a
landfill and dump it over there but now
because we had the economics of airing
figured out on the other side we could
incentivize him to give us this
pollution and make inks from it and and
turn it into even more valuable products
now pollution as we all know is a global
killer
we can't claim that our ink will solve
the world's pollution problem but it
does show what can be done if you look
at this problem slightly differently
look at this t-shirt i'm holding on
right now
this is made from same air ink i'm
talking about it's made from the same
pollution that is inside this petri dish
and the same pollution we are all are
breathing in when we are walking
outdoors and we are on our way to do
better than this thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]